hey youtubers is Charlie so you guys
requested a most powerful characters
video so let's break this down what I
did for the purposes of this list is
combine characters that have great power
and characters that have great magic so
power is a very relative term so this is
sort of a combination you can actually
break it down to most powerful generals
most powerful non magic people so this
is an amalgam of that this is a new
round of the game of Thrones giveaway
I'm giving away one of the enhanced
editions of the book all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video and I should also
say these characters are people who
appeared on the show or in the books
recently so I didn't include like very
big historical figures so here we go top
10 Khal Drogo with his full khalasar
about 40,000 people on horseback the
reason he made the list over people say
like the reach who could command upwards
of 80 to a hundred thousand troops is
because it does rocky on horseback or
even a blood rider is so much more
effective than a regular infantryman
from the reach or anywhere else in
Westeros so say things had gone down
differently during season 1 of the show
Khal Drogo's still lives they're able to
take his khalasar to Westeros they would
have been able to mow through most of
the villages in cities in Westeros now
some will be harder than others like it
would have been much harder to take the
red keep or even Casterly Rock or any of
the big capitals that are heavily
fortified but the thing is is it's not
just their effectiveness on horseback is
their battle tactics there's
slash-and-burn tactics so they can mow
through a town set everything on fire
and move on to the next one very quickly
before any of the lords are able to
marshal their troops so think of the
Battle of the bastards it took time to
get all those troops together to
organize them on the battlefield those
rocky just roll right in burn everything
to the ground and move on to the next
town almost immediately
number nine speaking of mowing down
people the wipes just a collective body
of whites they are unyielding they're
literally creatures of magic that are
already dead very hard to kill even if
you slash them cut off their limbs
they'll still come at you and they have
a force that's growing to be almost as
large as that of the reach in every new
battle feeds their ranks the night king
can just raise more any time he wants
and mass
all at the same time that was what that
scene from season five was all about you
kill a bunch of my troops well all those
people of yours that I killed I'm
turning them into my troops now so not
only is my army bigger it's growing at a
faster rate number eight is quake
because we haven't seen too much of her
power displayed but she's a shadow
binder like Melisandre from a shy
so they're both servants of the red god
and even though all their powers are
just a little bit different they have
relatively the same power so if you have
the ability to bring someone back to
life or call forth the might of the red
God then you were instantly bumped on
the list which is why number seven is
Thoreau civ Muir who in the books raises
Lady Stoneheart beric Dondarrion six
times how many times did the Lord of
Light bring him back six times I only
said the words it was the Lord that
brought him back so even though he's a
bit of a drunkard and actually lost his
faith for a while he was actually sent
to King's Landing to try and turn people
to the face of the red God so he was a
great failure in that sense because
Robert Baratheon was never going to
worship the red God he could care less
about religion once that hurt stark
hears about the atrocities and season
one committed by the mountain he sends
beric Dondarrion out to execute him on
the orders of the hand of the king
remember Ned still alive at this point
so he goes after him but the mountain
kills barek and that's when Thoreau's
unwittingly resurrects him for the first
time and that's what reignites his faith
so then he goes on to resurrect him five
more times after that and even the other
character so just sparing spoiler from
the book for the people that are still
reading the books so next one on the
list number six Melisandre even more
powerful has most of the same powers as
the other red priests the other shadow
binders raises Jon Snow from the dead
can birth shadow babies from those of
royal blood can cloak her appearance
using glamor magic and there's so many
other things that they haven't explained
they're purposefully very mysterious on
the TV show and even George R Martin has
only hinted at the type of sorcery that
they practice in his shy it's largely
regarded is the center of magic in
Westeros so it's sort of like a citadel
for magic users whereas the actual
Citadel which is the center of knowledge
in Westeros
really hates the idea of magic just to
diametric opposite centers of learning
in the world
number five is Daenerys with all three
of her dragons assuming that they're at
full strength and one of them isn't hurt
so she falls lower on the list if she
only has one dragon but like for most of
this list I assume no handicaps
so three dragons also a certain measure
of blood magic in her herself now a lot
of you have noticed the TV show Daenerys
is actually more powerful than book
Daenerys the big difference is in the
books she's just not constantly
fireproof so during season six when she
kills all the cows by setting the tent
on fire and it just walks out completely
under even her hair isn't burnt that
much he's got a little sit on her but
that's about it
that would only have been able to happen
in the books if somebody had invoked
blood magic like Murie master did during
season one when she was trying to save
Khal Drogo so a price was extracted life
for a life and that's what helped raise
her dragon that's what helped hatch them
and that's what allowed her to survive
that fire so it's a long regarded MIT
that all Targaryens are immune to fire
you may have heard the story about one
of the mad Targaryen Kings who believed
himself a dragon so he ate wildfire like
he literally drank it and it burned him
like a dry piece of kindling that was
Arian the monstrous one of the sons of
kingmaker Targaryen so he was also one
of the mad Kings one of the really
terrible people
who actually is going to appear in a
story that George our Martin is writing
later this year so we can actually come
back to him some of the mad Targaryen
Kings would like the mad caesar's they
had this really amazing stories it's
super WTF to just crazy things many
hundreds of years ago before what's
happening on the show right now
so coming towards the top of the list
these are all relatively close like
there isn't a big disparity between
these but number four the children of
the forest probably some of the most
powerful magic users or used to be some
of the most powerful magic users in the
world most of them have died off the TV
show has really cut down their story
there's a lot more of their history that
you talk about when you get into the war
with the first men the war with the
Andals how they smashed the arm of d'Or
with the hammer of waters the Isle of
faces which is this really mysterious
place with all these weird woods that's
where they signed the treaty with their
first big war with the first men they
this really deep connection with nature
the old gods most of them are green
seers that's actually something that
flows from them so there's a lot of
theories about how that got into the
genetic DNA of the Starks how bran
became a green sphere but even with all
their powerful magic there just aren't
enough of them to fight the night king
their creation who has become more
powerful and terrible than they are so
number three the night King the way the
TV shows portrayed him is that he is the
only night king to have existed even
though the book hints that there have
been several over the years does the way
they're created with the dragon glass
dagger to the heart indicates that you
could create another night king if you
really wanted to
so he's the weapon of mass destruction
that has all the same abilities as the
children of the force draws on the same
type of magic but has absolutely no
regard for life all he is created to do
is to end life he is death incarnate
that's his only purpose that's why they
created him during the war with the
first men but they lost control of them
now he's killing everyone without regard
for anything until there is no life left
never-ending nuclear winter there's
still a lot of theories about how he
brings the winter with him and how the
winter just perceives him so the show
might answer that a little bit but they
tend to be kind of vague so the books
will probably give us some more context
for that during winter winter and dream
of spring number two is brand Stark who
is now the new three-eyed Raven the
problem is is that even though he is the
most powerful magic user on the show he
doesn't fully understand everything he
has the sum total accumulated knowledge
of all of Westeros he's literally a
living rolodex of everything that's ever
happened so it's like you're summing
through a card catalog he just has
problems accessing all those memories
putting them into context so that's why
he's not at the top of the list but the
whole idea is is that you going to pick
out the most important stuff for
fighting the White Walkers learn the
history of the world how they were
created like he did during season six
and then learn how to stop him with the
tools that he has available to him so he
needs to learn all about Daenerys and
start actually working with these people
to marshal forces against the White
Walkers but number one is hands down the
Bloodraven
so may he rest in peace but he just had
all the powers that he gave to brand but
he had hundreds of
years to learn how to use his powers the
big weakness is is that he had reached
the end of his lifespan like he sensed
that he was eventually going to die he's
not immortal but he is extremely
long-lived
so the same thing will happen to Brandt
if he's not killed himself he could live
a very long life just living on that
pace that the children of the forest
feed to the three-eyed Raven but that
all just depends on how you think the
story is going to go down who's going to
be left alive after they're finally able
to defeat the night king let me know in
the comments who do you think the most
powerful character is on the show alive
or dead like Aegon the conquerer is more
powerful than Daenerys he was much
better with his dragons he'd had more
time to learn about he grew up with
dragons in a way that Daenerys did not
the Bloodraven had all kinds of powers
that we haven't seen bran demonstrate
yet that's going to be one of the most
exciting things seeing him unlock all
those extra new abilities I know
everybody's wondering about bringing the
wall down so night King Brand Bloodraven
probably the three most powerful
characters on the show sort of tied in
terms of power levels but the Bloodraven
just had more time to study his
abilities so if you want to recommend a
bonus video for next week's game of
Thrones just let me know in the comments
a lot of you were asking for video about
like the biggest characters does a TV
shows cut out congratulations to last
week's Game of Thrones giveaway winner
it's a Morningstar please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details what's
going to happen tonight is I have that
new Walking Dead episode video so I will
see you guys when that post while you
wait for that you can click here for new
Star Wars Episode 8 and you can click
here to learn all about the Starks
history with the night King in the White
Walkers thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys in the
next video